how fundamental do you think is
consciousness to the human mind
i ask this from almost like a robotics
perspective so in your study of sleep
do you think
the the hard question of consciousness
that it feels like something
to be us
is that like a nice little feature like
a like a like a quark of our mind or is
it somehow fundamental because sleep
feels like we take we take a step out of
that consciousness a little bit
so from all your study of sleep
do you think consciousness is like
deeply part of who we are or is it just
a nice trick
i think it's a deeply embedded feature
that i can imagine has
a whole panoply of biological benefits
but to your point about sleep what is
interesting if you do a lot of dream
research and we've done
some it's very very rare
at all in fact for you to end up
becoming someone other than who you are
in your dreams now you can have third
person perspective dreams where you can
see yourself in the dream as if you're
sort of
you know you've risen above your
your physical being
but for the most part it's very rare
that we lose our sense of conscious self
and maybe i'm sort of doing a sleight of
hand because it's really what i'm saying
is it's very rare that we lose our sense
of who we are in dreams we never do
now that's not to suggest that dreams
aren't utterly
bizarre and
i mean you know when you slept last
night which i know um may have been
perhaps a little less than than me but
when you went into dreaming you know you
became flagrantly psychotic
and there are five essentially good
reasons firstly you started to see
things which were not there so you were
hallucinating
second you believed things that couldn't
possibly be true so you were delusional
third you became confused about time and
place and person so you're suffering
from what we would call disorientation
fourth you have wildly fluctuating
emotions something that psychiatrists
will call being affectively labile
and then how wonderful you woke up this
morning and you forgot most if not all
of that dream experience so you're
suffering from amnesia if you had to
experience any one of those five things
while you're awake you would probably be
seeking psychological help
but so i placed that as a backdrop
against your astute question because
despite all of that
psychosis
there is still a present
self
nested at the heart of it meaning that i
think it's very difficult for us
to
abandon our conscious sense of self and
if it's that hard you know the old adage
in some ways that you can't outrun your
shadow but here it's more of a
philosophical question which is about
the conscious mind and what the state of
consciousness actually means in a human
being
so i think that that to me you can
you become
so dislocated from so many other
rational ways of waking consciousness
but one thing that won't go away that
won't get perturbed
or sort of
you know
manacled is this your sense of conscious
self yeah that's a strong sign that
consciousness is fundamental to the
human mind
um or we're just creatures of habit
we've gotten used to having
consciousness maybe it just takes a lot
of uh
either chemical substances or a lot of
like
mental work to escape that
i mean it's like trying to launch
a rocket
you know the energy that has to be put
in to create escape velocity
from the gravitational pull of this
thing called planet earth is immense
yeah well the same thing is true
for
for us to abandon our sense of conscious
self the amount of biological the amount
of substances the amount of wacky stuff
that you have to do to truly get escaped
velocity from your conscious self
what does that tell us about then the
fundamental
state of our conscious self
yeah it also probably says that that uh
it's quite useful to have consciousness
for uh for survival and for just
operation in this world and perhaps for
intelligence i'm one of the on the ai
side people that think
that
intelligence requires consciousness so
like high levels of general intelligence
requires consciousness most people in
the ai field think like consciousness
and intelligence are fundamentally
different you can build a computer
that's super intelligent it doesn't have
to be conscious
i think that
if you define super intelligence by
being good at chess yes but if you
define
super intelligence as being able to
operate in this living world of humans
and be able to perform all kinds of
different tasks consciousness
it seems to be somehow fundamental
to uh like to to to richly integrate
yourself into the human experience into
society it feels like you have to be a
conscious being
but then we don't even know what
consciousness is and we certainly don't
know how to engineer it in our machines
i love the fact that there are still
questions that are so embryonic
because you know i suspect it's the same
with you
answers to me are simply ways to get to
more questions you know it's questions
where
you know questions turn me on answers
less so
and i love the fact that we are still
embryonic in our sense of arguing about
even what the definition of
consciousness is but i also find it
fascinating i i think it's thoroughly
delightful to absorb yourself in the
thought
think about the brain and we can move
back across the complexity of phylogeny
from you know humans to mammals to sort
of birds to reptiles amphibians fish and
you can
bacteria whatever you want and you can
go through this and say okay where is
the hard line of you know what we would
define as consciousness and
and i'm sure it's got something to do
with the complexity of the neural system
of that i'm fairly certain
but
to me it's always been fascinating
so what is it then you know is it that i
just keep adding neurons to a petri dish
and i just keep adding them and adding
them and adding them at some point when
i hit a critical mass of interconnected
neurons that is the mass of the you know
the interconnected human brain then
bingo
all of a sudden it kicks into gear and
we have consciousness like a phase shift
phase transition of some kind correct
yeah but there is something about the
complexity of the nervous system that i
think is fundamental to consciousness
and the reason i bring that up is
because
when we're trying to then think about
creating it in an artificial way does
that inform us as to the complexity that
we should be looking at in terms of
development i also think that it's a
missed opportunity in the
sort of digital space for us to try to
recreate human consciousness
we've already got human consciousness
what if we were to think about
creating some other form of why do we
have to think that
the ultimate in the creation of you know
an artificial intelligence is the
replication
you know
of a human
state of consciousness can we not think
outside of our own
consciousness and believe that there is
something even more incredible or
more complementary more orthogonal
um
so i'm sometimes
perplexed that people
are trying to mimic human consciousness
rather than think about creating
something that's different yeah i think
of human consciousness or consciousness
in general is this magic
um
super power that allows us to deeply
experience the world and just as you're
saying i don't think that superpower has
to take the exact flavor as humans have
that's my love for robots
i would love to
add the ability to robots that can
experience the world and other humans
uh deeply i'm humbled by the fact that
that idea does not necessarily need to
look anything like
how humans experience the world
but there's a dance of um
human to robot connection the same way
human to dog a human to cat connection
that there's a there's a there's a magic
there to that interaction and i'm not
sure how to create that magic but it's a
worthy effort i also love just exactly
as you said
on the question of consciousness or
engineering consciousness
the fun thing about this problem
is it seems obvious to me that a hundred
years from now
no matter what we do today
uh people if we're still here
will
laugh at how silly our notions were so
like it's almost impossible for me to
imagine that we will truly solve this
problem
fully
in my lifetime
and and more than that everything we'll
do
will be silly 100 years from now but
it's still a war that makes it fun to me
because it's like you have the full
freedom to not even be right
just to try just to try as freedom and
uh
and i that's how i see that t-shirt
please
i love that so i and you know the human
robot interaction is fascinating because
it's like it's like watching dancing
i've been uh
dancing tango recently and just it's
like
there is no goal the goal is to create
something magical
and uh
whether consciousness or emotion or
elegance of movement all those things
uh aid in the creation of the magic and
it's a free it's it's an art form to
explore how how to make that um
how to create that in a way that's
compelling yeah i love that the line in
sense of a woman with al pacino where
he's speaking about the tango and he
said really it's just freedom that
if you get tangled up you just keep
tangoing on
you